[Musica]
[Applauso]
buongiorno
innanzi tutto bene io voglio raccontarvi
due storie due storie personali che
hanno cambiato la mia vita che hanno
cambiato delle cose importanti
la prima prende lo spunto dal titolo che
vedete ogni problema una soluzione
quindi vi parlerò di una storia che
riguarda questa coppia problema
soluzione poi quando il ted mi ha
chiesto di preparare diciamo questo
questo racconto la mia mente e ha
cercato un secondo tema è
improvvisamente mi è apparso nello
schermo della mente un'altra parola
chiave che ritengo molto importante che
ha influenzato molto la mia vita e che
dell ascolto ascoltare queste slide
rappresentano questi due elementi ma la
domanda che potreste farmi voi è questa
ma come sono connessi problema soluzione
con un ascolto
c'è un intreccio c'è una relazione non
la voglio svelare subito immagino che la
capirete durante il corso del mio
racconto ma poi cercheremo alla fine di
trovare una spiegazione bene palloncini
l'esperienza che vi voglio raccontare
risale circa una decina di anni fa ho
frequentato un corso per diventare coach
e durante questa esperienza il maestro
il super coach ci ha fatto sedere a
cerchio ci ha spiegato che ci avrebbe
raccontato anzi fatto fare un'esperienza
per non pensare ma cosa incredibile
io vi racconterò questa esperienza
e se volete ciascuno di voi adesso può
farla proprio qui in questo momento ori
maestro la prima cosa che ci ha chiesto
di fare prendere una postura fisica
quindi schiena sentire la vostra schiena
schiena diritta diritta se volete
diritta poggiata bene contro lo
schienale la seconda pastura sono i
piedi e le gambe cioè cercate di avere
consapevolezza del vostro peso
appoggiando il peso delle vostre gambe
parallele sul terreno sul pavimento e
appoggiate la mano dopo di che il
maestro disse ma per l'esperienza che
voglio farmi fare
chi vuole può chiudere gli occhi
quindi anche voi potete tenere aperti
gli occhi o chiudere gli occhi
che cosa ci ci suggerisce il maestro è
quello che vedete proprio immaginate che
la vostra mente che è piena di rumore di
pensieri che vi arrivano cercate di far
entrare nello schermo della vostra mente
dei palloncini i palloncini sono
un'esperienza che abbiamo da bambini
quindi noi sappiamo che cos'è un
palloncino con il suo filo quindi
cominciamo a vedere a proiettare nello
schermo della nostra mente questi
palloncini e che cosa ci ha chiesto al
maestro dice bene prendete il filo
oppure la mano alla mano della mente e
spostate questi palloncini verso
l'esterno
c'è fatto in modo che questi palloncini
che stanno entrando escano innescano
escano esco escono a un certo punto non
so potete provare a farlo vi accorgerete
che i padroncini possono effettivamente
uscire quando sono usciti tutti che cosa
succede e bello schermo e è quello che
sarà colorato sarà grigio sarà azzurro
sarà rossa dipende da voi c'è uno
schermo pulito ecco questo è il momento
in cui non c'è più nessun pensiero che
vi faccia da rumore di fondo cioè non
c'è più nessun disturbo
ecco questo è stato un grandissimo
insegnamento insegnamento per
predisporci a che cosa all'ascolto
perché per ascoltare bisogna avere la
mente sgombera no pulita ecco ho visto
che qualcuno di voi l'ha fatto quanti
hanno visto i palloncini potete alzare
la mano
wow un terzo e quanti sono riusciti a
far uscire i palloncini quasi tutti i
complimenti veramente di applaudire
ecco la scorta è una cosa incredibile
perché la seconda episodio che vi voglio
raccontare che in chi veramente
straordinario mi è capitato due anni fa
nel 2016
perché ho frequentato un corso
organizzato dalle mighty da quale
argomento dall'ascolto sono che lui ci
ha dato un messaggio diverso non ci ha
fatto fare questo questo gioco che avete
provato ma ci ha detto delle cose di
testa non interessanti quanti tipi di
ascolto possiamo fare cene elencati 4
che io vi racconto brevemente due
sicuramente li conoscete uno addirittura
lo usate tutti i giorni
ve lo dico in inglese download scarico
di un immagine di un file di una
fotografia lo fate andando in internet
quindi scaricate qualcosa e poi magari
lo andate a vedere il giorno dopo il
pomeriggio tra un po questo è il primo
ascolto il secondo ascolto è già più
impegnativo però sicuramente lo fate del
fatto si chiama ascolto fattuale cioè
cercate di estrarre dalle cose che vi
vengono raccontate i fatti cioè infatti
cosa vuol dire numeri dati no cose
concrete pratiche il terzo tipo di
ascolto e più impegnativo anche se la
natura umana nella vostra mente è
predisposta a farlo però non è così
frequente el ascolto empatico cosa vuol
dire vuol dire che vi mettete nei panni
di un'altra persona e sentite che cosa
sente lui le emozioni le paure le ansie
il piacere o no quindi vestite i suoi
panni i suoi vestiti e infine l'ultimo
ascolto molto impegnativo molto più
impegnativa molto interessante che
potreste che sicuramente fatte ma
potreste migliorare
si chiama ascolto generativo cosa vuol
dire vuol dire che man mano che
ascoltate l'altra persona fate
funzionare la vostra mente possibilmente
liberata
magari con la tecnica del palloncino
per generare immagini per esempio oppure
delle cose più complicate metafore
oppure una cosa che io trovo
difficilissima ma magari a qualcuno
riesce la postura la gestirà non c'è la
risposta non verbale quindi queste
queste tre cose possono essere una
risposta generativa che aiuta poi
l'altra persona perché gli date una
prospettiva diversa quindi vedete che
l'ascolto può far parte della nostra
vita quotidiana della nostra esperienza
e quindi sostanzialmente è una cosa
molto molto importante
bene adesso come nei film cambiamo scena
cambiamo scena e la scena si rifà al
titolo del del nostro incontro no cioè
ogni problema una soluzione quindi
problema soluzione ecco l'episodio che
vi voglio raccontare per me
personalmente avviene nel 2005
io all'epoca io faccio l'imprenditore
società diciamo che aiuta le aziende a
fare innovazione e o lavoro lavoravo per
una grande azienda diciamo del food del
del cibo dall'alimentare per un anno ho
lavorato per cercare in giro per il
mondo
le cose più interessanti chi ha detto le
cose più interessanti sulla innovazione
e abbiamo scoperto che nell'anno 2000
c'è qualche anno prima una grande
azienda che sicuramente conoscete
attraverso i suoi prodotti l'azienda
americana si chiama procter and gamble
nell'anno 2000 e 30 miliardi di dollari
di fatturato
enorme la parte debole è in crisi non fa
più profitti rischia veramente grosso
arriva un nuovo presidente si chiama la
flai questo signore qui convoca tutti il
tutto il suo staff e gli dà una notizia
cioè dice io voglio cambiare e procter
and gamble o una strategia in mente è la
mia strategia è la seguente voglio usare
utilizzare
i talenti le tecnologie che oggi non con
noi non conosciamo non frequentiamo
quindi voglio che in cinque anni in un
periodo di cinque anni
metà dei prodotti della proteina di
apple non nascano grazie a un intervento
una collaborazione esterna
ecco per capire la violenza uso questo
termine del messaggio
dovete sapere quanti ricercatori aveva
procter and gamble nell'anno 2000 8.000
8mila persone
era una delle più grandi aziende le
aziende che aveva la più grande
concentrazione di ricerca e sviluppo del
mondo
no lui ci riesce riesce a fare questa
cosa come beh non solo attraverso
diciamo la sua idea ma attraverso alcune
persone della procter dei broker cioè
delle aziende che nel frattempo si erano
formate per mettere in contatto i
problemi della procter coni solutori è
una domanda che vi potreste fare che a
me incuriosito molto e ci sono riuscito
sono riuscito a dare risposta solo pochi
da pochi anni ma le persone nel mondo
hanno realmente no fa ho conoscenze
utili per risolvere i problemi
un milione 10 milioni voi sapete che
oggi siamo lo ha detto un oratore poco
fa 7,6 miliardi di persone
beh il calcoli più recenti che ho visto
è poi magari sono sbagliati cioè non
credeteci troppo dicono che ci sono 70
70 70 milioni di persone con how
tecnologico di business rilevante che
può servire sembra ragionevole no sembra
ragionevole
bene quindi che cosa vuol dire questa
cosa qui che problema e soluzione sono
assolutamente coinvolgenti una cosa
interessante questa quando la flai
nell'anno 2000 inventa questa strategia
questa strategia non ha un nome e un
idea no
solo tre anni dopo un professore
americano che che vi cito che si chiama
euro chaz bono dell'università berkeley
e quindi università importante scrive un
libro
voi sapete che gli americani sono
intelligenti ma anche scaltri no quindi
scrivono i libri con degli scopi lui
inventa una parola quindi chiama questo
sistema di la flat open innovation
tradotto in italiano
innovazione aperta e da quel momento in
avanti esplode no questa questa idea no
si sviluppa in tutto il mondo e oggi se
voi aprite un qualunque sito web che
scrivete open innovazione aperta open
innovation trovate 100.000 risposte
gli italiani hanno accolto con grande
fantasia il grande capacità questo
questo messaggio quindi l'innovazione
aperta per me è stata una svolta anche
tim prendi imprenditore ci ho cominciato
a lavorarci a lavorare là con con le
imprese su questo quindi questo è
sostanzialmente quello che vi volevo
dire ecco forse voi potreste avere un
obiezione bell'anticipo cioè qualcuno di
voi potrebbe dirmi sì ma connettere
problema assoluzione beh ne parlavano
gli antichi greci socrate aristotile no
gli ato misti cioè no collegare queste
due cose
cosa è cambiato beh quello che è
cambiato e che oggi open innovation la
fate la facciamo tutti cioè tutti in
questa stanza la fanno
mi porto un esempio non vi chiedo quanti
usano internet perché ci sono 6 miliardi
di utenti nel mondo
quindi direi che il 99 per cento di voi
usa internet quando voi avete un
problema a una curiosità chi è che non è
mai andato su wikipedia
chi non ha mai digitato è scritto magari
come sfidano il proprio problema
linguaggio naturale e vi vengono fuori
magari un milione di risposte ma nella
prima pagina o nelle prime tre pagine
credo che sia un'abitudine che
che avete trovate delle cose
interessanti quindi l'innovazione aperta
significa mente aperta
sostanzialmente quindi una è
un'abitudine che abbiamo ma che
caratteristica di questo periodo storico
che è molto importante
bene le due storie sono queste ho ancora
qualche secondo per sciogliere la
promessa no iniziale ma come sono
connesse queste cose quindi un problema
è qualche cosa che no vi spinge a
un'azione come potete risolverla qui
vedete nella slide una soluzione
tradizionale che viene chiamata
innovazione chiusa forse un po cattiva
cioè l'innovazione tradizionale e quella
in cui voi rispondete oppure risponde la
vostra cerchia più vicina di consulenti
di fornitori se siete un azienda l'altra
alternativa è quella che vi ho spiegato
prima raccontandogli la storia di
procter and gamble ho scritto crowd per
dire folla no cioè usiamo il mondo
questo è onestamente e quello che
facciamo oggi da adesso in avanti cioè
ci facciamo aiutare ci facciamo
supportare da tanta altra gente
e allora l'ascolto a cosa serve per
capire l'ascolto vi cito una frase che
probabilmente conoscete già sin da
piccoli
molto spesso ci dicono un problema ben
definito a metà dell'opera
cioè con un proxy e definiamo bene un
problema siamo a metà dell'opera
quindi cosa vuol dire vuol dire che per
risolvere un problema dobbiamo avere
molta attenzione a definire il problema
spesso inseguiamo problemi inesistenti
problemi modesti problemi non
determinanti e quindi il primo la prima
cosa dobbiamo fare è ascoltarci però
attenzione che questo è quello che io ho
imparato che vorrei trasferirmi
importante ascoltarci anche ascoltare
gli altri
quindi l'ascolto deve essere applicato
soprattutto in prima battuta sul
problema questo praticamente la risposta
che vi dovevo sono contento di averlo
raccontato e vi saluto e vi ringrazio
[Applauso]